también vive este jueves 19 de noviembre
una jornada nacional de paro convocada
precisamente por el comité nacional de
paro que está formado por sindicatos y
también por agentes sociales esta será
la primera de las marchas que se vivan
esta especial semana cuando se conmemora
el primer aniversario de la el paro
nacional de 2019 iniciado el 21 de
noviembre cuando fueron las marchas más
multitudinarias en colombia en décadas
además de esta marcha hoy que ha salido
el sol después de días de lluvia y que
parece que poco a poco se van
congregando más gente en los próximos
días también se juntarán estudiantes de
esta marcha los sindicatos están
reclamando un pliego de emergencias al
gobierno de iván duque por los efectos
que está teniendo el cómic 19 en los
trabajadores especialmente ahora que el
país ha entrado en recesión por primera
vez en dos décadas pero también están
aquí para protestar contra la violencia
que vive el país cuando este 2020 se han
registrado más de 70 masacres el doble
que en 2019 y también por la violencia
policial con el recuerdo de septiembre
cuando 13 personas 13 jóvenes fueron
asesinados en su mayoría por disparos
la policía bueno nosotros estamos
reivindicando el derecho al trabajo
estamos reivindicando la renta básica
para los sectores más empobrecidos
estamos reivindicando el desarrollo de
políticas de empleo sacar al país de la
informalidad en que actualmente se
desenvuelve que el gobierno se siente
con el comando nacional de de paro al
negociar el pliego de emergencia que se
logre el decreto 11 74 y que en general
asumamos la actitud proclive al diálogo
y a la negociación
este es un gobierno que ni dialoga ni
con certa ni negocia absolutamente nada